Leo DiCaprio is taking on a new role as
a hero in real life the Titanic actor
helps save a man who had fallen off a
yacht in the Caribbean it all unfolded
after DiCaprio and his pals heard of the
stress call while on their rental boat
they rushed to the area to try and find
the man and sure enough they did the man
had apparently been lost at sea off the
small island of Saba and had been
treading water for an incredible 11
hours one source from the rescue
reportedly said the captain of Leo's
boat but the man's chances of survival
at one-in-a-billion yeah the man himself
said when he was pulled aboard he said I
should have died yeah yeah now I look he
I don't want to say he's not a hero
right like you know he's on a rental
boat the crew got a distress call and
said mr. DiCaprio do you mind if we go
look for this guy and he said yes he
could have said no boat in the area
though that responded that's rescue the
word hero is a big word you know he's
not wearing the cap what are you I hope
he was doing I think you should ask the
guy got pulled out of the water
you